Carrusel de las artes
María Carolina piña
[Música]
bienvenidos una vez más a este espacio
donde les hablamos de cultura y que les
presentamos desde nuestros estudios en
París Pónganse cómodos que a
continuación los invitamos a descubrir
un poquito de la actualidad artística en
Francia
la talentosa y excéntrica actriz Sara
bernaj es objeto de una nutrida muestra
en el petipale de París cuando se
cumplen 100 años de su desaparición
conoceremos todas las facetas de este
artista Total que impuso la capital
francesa a sus pies Tendremos una clase
magistral sobre maracas un instrumento
típico de los países del Caribe de la
mano del maraquero alirio José torrealba
quien estuvo de gira por Europa y lleno
de ritmo nuestros estudios y en nuestra
Crónica musical conversaremos con el
cantante
un pionero del hip hop seregalés quien
pasó por París para promocionar su
último trabajo
que mezcla gospel Soul jazz y
percusiones
[Música]
fue la primera influencer francesa la
actriz de teatro sarabianaj fallecida
hace 100 años es homenajeada en el
petipalé de París una exposición con 400
piezas que muestran Las mil y un caras
de este icono internacional que sigue
inspirando a la cultura francesa
visitamos esta muestra con Melissa barra
como se fabrica una súper estrella saga
Bernard fue quien creó la receta la diva
Rebelde del teatro francés del siglo XIX
fue la primera en alcanzar la fama Sin
fronteras nacida en 1844
prefería volverse monja que casarse su
familia optó por el conservatorio de
teatro donde conoció el éxito de forma
tardía
de la muestra
empezó su carrera en el teatro con
pequeños papeles fue actriz de la comedy
francés y del teatro del odion su primer
éxito lo tuvo encarnando a saneto un
personaje masculino un trovador luego
interpretó a la reina en Rubí blash de
Víctor Hugo así se volvió famosa acumuló
papeles célebres del teatro como la dama
de las camelias Teodora o fedra para
Berna de inspiro artistas de su época
como Alfonso muja que la representó en
muchos afiches también a George cuyo
retrato imponente es una pieza central
de la muestra en su salón Sara Bernard
recibía todo un séquito de artistas era
el centro del París mundano
[Música]
actriz versátil ícono de la moda y mujer
liberada con múltiples amantes saga
Berna fue la primera influencer de
Francia y sin duda del mundo su
excentricidad no tenía límites
tenía muchísimos admiradores y su imagen
causaba gran sensación la prensa los
diarios adoraban entrar en su espacio
privado la exposición muestra cuán
excéntrica y original era y su
fascinación por lo macabro la vemos en
una foto durmiendo en un féretro y en
otra usando un sombrero en forma de
murciélago además vivía rodeada de
animales como su aligator llamado Ali
Gaga que murió de una sobredosis de
champañas por todos los continentes fue
hasta cisne y América Latina tenía un
tren especialmente Dedicado para ella
con su nombre encima en la muestra vemos
sus viajes a Sudamérica difícil y a
grandes ciudades donde sus obras
triunfaron
Sara Bernard fue un embajadora de lujo
francés y de la lengua francesa Recibió
la legión de honor por difundir el
idioma en todo el mundo
la muestra revela un aspecto desconocido
de su vida fue una gran artista plástico
[Música]
una pintura escritora y escultora eso
pocos lo saben realizó Bustos
fantásticos como El retrato funerario de
su único esposo Jack damala pero también
esculturas de bronce con algas que
recogían las playas se trata de obras
poéticas y muy impresionantes de su
carrera
Murió como vivió en la gloria con un
millón de admiradores en las calles de
París para un último adiós
y a continuación una clase magistral de
maracas un instrumento utilizado en la
música folclórica de varios países
latinoamericanos pero que ha conquistado
otros estilos musicales es lo que nos
contó el maraquero alirio José torrealba
en su gira por Europa y su alto en
nuestros estudios y con él podrán
apreciar que todo tiene su arte
[Música]
Mi nombre es arito torrealba vengo de
Venezuela y soy maraquero profesional
[Música]
alirio José torrealba es percusionista
de formación pero sea especializado en
la técnica de las maracas un instrumento
presente en varios países del Caribe
aunque se cree que su origen se
encuentra en Venezuela
las maracas se utilizan para la música
folclórica venezolana Es que la
compartimos entre Colombia y Venezuela
es un instrumento popular tenemos
muchísimos tipos de maracas y las
principales son de origen indígena se la
antes se le llamaba maraca con k o
malaca y esto se originó en el Orinoco
de la parte de Venezuela las maracas
dentro de la música folclórica
venezolana es muy importante porque
marcan el ritmo porque tenemos el arpa y
el 4 y la abandona el abandona y el arpa
son instrumentos Melódicos y el 4 es un
instrumento armónico de acompañamiento
las maracas sonó que marcan el ritmo y
todo lo que hace el 4 lo hace la maraca
al mismo tiempo
[Música]
las maracas típicas venezolanas o
colombianas se componen de un mango y de
una tapara otoma un fruto esférico
vaciado que se rellena con semillas O
perlas de plástico materiales simples
que permiten un sinfín de posibilidades
sonidos y ritmos son muchísimos golpes
son aproximadamente en mi libro podemos
encontrar 64 golpes del joropo llanero
entre los que está El pajarillo zumba
que zumba guacharaca hay muchísimos
ritmos del joropo llanero y este tipo de
maracas se utiliza para para ejecutarlo
lo que le llamamos los golpes especiales
tenemos la ola o wave que es esto otro
golpe especial es el escobillado
se llama así porque es la misma acción
de la escoba de poder barrer es el
sonido que ejecuta esto es
utilizadas en bailes tradicionales como
el joropo las maracas han conquistado
otros Horizontes musicales las maracas
ahora tienen una amplia gama rítmica ya
estamos adaptando este instrumento que
es netamente folklórico venezolano
a ritmos tradicionales de otros países
como por ejemplo el merengue dominicano
si la güira hace un a caballo y es un
ritmo dominicano yo lo puedo hacer con
las maracas
si podemos hacer un pan biche
también podemos adaptarlos a la salsa
sí podemos hacer bolero también
este instrumento me llamó mucho la
atención porque en el momento que emigré
de mi país a Colombia era el único
instrumento que yo cargaba conmigo Este
es el instrumento que con el que toquen
las calles las maracas me conectan
directamente con Venezuela y es un
instrumento que me identifica como
venezolano
[Música]
la música nos lleva también a explorar
otro continente lleno de percusiones y
de ritmo y es por supuesto África más
precisamente senegal de donde es el
artista que nos presenta hoy natalio
Olivares 1 de Los Pioneros del hip hop
africano la Natalia Hola María Carolina
su nombre es fata Freddy y con su grupo
su ex grupo dará Jane family se hizo un
nombre famosísimo en el mundo del rap en
senegal su país y todo esto significa la
escuela de la calle y suena así
[Música]
para Freddy sin artífice saca su nuevo
disco en solitario el disco se llama
tables willem su voz Es su fuerza y su
cuerpo su instrumento
regresó con un estilo que estoy
actualmente desarrollando que es la
música orgánica basada en la percusión
corporal con la voz me mantuve en el
mismo enfoque que tenía antes con el
grupo dara Jay family pero con un nuevo
camino y se nota con el single tables
que significa que el viento está girando
y que terminará soplando de nuestro lado
es una canción que llama a la
positividad la vida puede pura pero por
muy larga que sea la noche el día
termina por llegar todo se agobiado
[Música]
sin artífice de nuevo Lo digo porque
realmente es un cantante muy Modesto
farah nuevo un segundo álbum con esa
técnica que es una percusión vocal y
corporal esa técnica que él solo conoce
los bombos que son más graves se hacen
con la voz
los redoblantes se hacen con las palmas
y los otros tambores se hacen con la
boca para reproducir el Debut
todo está entrelazado y alternamos
percusiones con el pecho y la boca
están también los sintetizadores
[Música]
hacemos mezclas de sonidos y
onomatopeyas que componen la base de
todo el distritonomatopé quizá la
composición de tu lado
una música 100% orgánica sin tecnología
gospel percusiones jazz y onomatopeya
son la base de la música de
notar que la mayoría de sus instrumentos
son hechos con material reciclado tal
como él lo hacía en la calle cuando niño
en las calles de daca gracias Natalia
Olivares por presentarnos este artista
senegalés
que habla francés inglés
el dialecto de su país Muchísimas
gracias con él los dejamos gracias por
su sintonía y hasta la próxima
[Música]